there's so many ways that you can expand
your creative and math skills without
even really realizing that you're doing
it like for me i'm a big board game fan
um and i realize that there's so many
games that involve
math and learning how to
solve problems and
sometimes like just uh when you're
cooking i love to bake and so i feel
like i'm constantly using like fractions
and learning how to do proportions um
just because i'm doing things that i
love so i feel like the best way to
expand your your mathematical and
creative skills are just doing what you
love to do because probably it has
some kind of math in it and um some kind
of creativity try to connect what you're
learning to your real life it's really
easy to be in the classroom and think
that it's siloed uh and it's orthogonal
from the world around you
the more we can connect what we're
learning in the classroom to our real
life either via sports or entertainment
politics news whatever
the connection that you make between
math and your real life will really help
you appreciate the skills
and the methods and find ways to
transfer them outside of just the
classroom alone
you